The joe rogan experience.
It's just weird man.
It's just,
I'd never,
I've never seen us so divided and part of it has to do with Trump for sure.
There's like this reaction like that they feel like I'm really obligated to act.
People feel obligated to act and try to make things change,
which I think is ultimately good.
All this thing,
the all of what's going on right now does not concern me nearly as much as it
does a lot of other people.
Right.
Cause I feel like people are already reacting to it and already going,
what in the fuck you know?
And,
and the ship is already starting to write itself.
Well the Oscars was the lowest rated I think in the history of the Oscar heard
that.
But it's also 26 million people watched.
That's a lot of fucking people.
That's a lot.
Don't Shit on someone who got 26 million people.
I saw that.
They were afraid it,
it'd be people get very kind of like,
wow,
we're getting political here.
And when they looked at the numbers,
the numbers where they were comparing it to like 2013 there were down 5 million
from 2013 I think it was.
Guess what wasn't around 2013 Netflix.
True.
There's a lot more shit to watch.
What's it down from last year?
There's definitely people that are bored with Hollywood though.
Like enough.
Well,
they Hollywood's over Rachel.
I think Hollywood tends to be,
what bothers me about Hollywood is there virtuous virtue signaling.
Like they're going to set an example.
You fucking guys like you want to be liked.
Okay.
And you're as fickle as it gets.
They were the same people that were standing up and clapping for Roman Polanski.
I'm sorry man.
Well,
some of them were,
some of them were really saying some ridiculous shit.
I mean like,
come on guys.
It's a long time ago and he's drugged and sodomized.
A 13 year old.
I think he fucked more than one too.
Yeah.
So guess what?
I can't have that guy.
You're not kidding.
They wanted to sign a petition to bring him back in the country.
I can't forgive that no stay in France.
Well they want to bring it back to the country to arrest them and they're really
trying hard to do that.
And there's people that resist that.
I think he's an amazing artist and you know,
artists are just different.
Be Consistent though,
you know you can system.
That's where I draw the line.
You can't drug kids fucking with the,
I mean Asia Argento who was one of the,
one of the people that came out against Harvey Weinstein,
she had been raped by him apparently.
And then she had a sexual relationship for 10 years afterwards,
which by the way,
people are like,
God,
I actually forgive that because people go back to the trauma,
right?
They want to relive it on their own terms.
But she signed the petition to for,
for Roman Polanski to,
you know,
to be freed when he was put under arrest and I believe it was Switzerland.
Now that's not consistent.
I'm sorry man.
I'm sorry.
But if that guy is just as bad as yeah,
you can see the petition online.
What was her perspective?
She was somebody who thought Roman Polanski.
Should not be prosecuted for something that happened a long time ago.
She signed that petition.
I would never sign that petition.
So there's a lot of disconnect.
So I have a big problem with that sort of disconnect.
That's a problem.
I don't know this woman,
I don't know her.
Um,
I believe her.
I believe what she says about Harvey Weinstein.
Uh,
and again,
I,
you know,
people are like,
well,
she went back to the scene of the crime.
That's very common,
but don't sign a petition and then now be this leading voice in this whole anti
harassment.
It's like,
I think it's very inconsistent.
I think you have to pay,
you have to at least answer to that.
Did she comment on once she saw there was a mia culpa there,
but it's very inconsistent in it and there's a lot of that out there.
There's a lot of that.
We should make sure that she definitely did that.
You'll see it.
Just see if you can Google the young dreamy will say,
it feels like something that,
you know,
I looked it up.
I actually looked it up.
I wanted to see who had signed that petition and I came across her name and I
was like,
Whoa,
that doesn't make any sense to me.
You know,
it just doesn't make any sense man.
I don't get it.
I don't know enough about what happened.
I know that he drugged in and saw the mas,
some younger girl.
She was 13 and her mom dropped her off I believe.
And it was,
why was she there?
Yeah,
it was the 70s men.
People would just free relationship every bit of 20 all that shit in here man.
But I believe he knew she was 13 and then he knew he was going to go away to
jail and he left the country,
Jesus Christ
and say,
and then apparently there's another woman that he had done that too.
So imagine being on the scene back then.
How weird that must have been like there,
there had been like think about Roman Polanski making movies and like what the
1970s right?
Yeah.
I mean God trying to tell.
It's only it.
Only days.
Yeah.
Amazing.
If they'd only been making movies for like a few decades.
It was a real new thing.
She's signed the petition,
but I found a tweet she just put,
she put out a couple of months ago where she said she regretted doing it.
Hard to regret it.
The signing the petition years ago,
she said a mistake of implants.
He's a filmmaker whose work I admire greatly,
but if I ever see him,
I'll spit in his face if he's lucky.
Yeah,
but you signed the petition.
I already regretted signing the petition years ago already felt it was a
mistake.
No excuses.
It was stupid with this indicates a proud in a behavior that if true and I
believe it to be true,
is beyond unforgivable.
Well,
I think,
I think you,
you got a good point though about you.
She made a mistake and there is something that happens to people that had been
violated.
Sometimes they blame themselves.
That's what I say sometimes to forgive that and there could be a little of that
in her decision making process too.
I can't,
I could be a little bit of wanting to be in with Hollywood.
You know,
that's not ethically or morally consistent.
No.
And she fucked up and she realized she fucked up.
But you're also coming after people now,
you know,
if we're gonna if we're,
we're going to end and a lot of these people you know deserve to become after.
But you know we have to be consistent here.
Right.
But isn't she beacons being consistent by just saying that she fucked up,
she realized that she fucked out.
Well there are a lot of people are saying that once they get caught,
well that petition they type of petition doesn't mean Jack Shit.
They ain't letting them,
he doesn't matter.
He's signed it.
And it was,
I was that,
I don't know anybody that would sign that and it like I would never sign that
petition.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Be Consistent if I'm,
so if the guy came to America and got arrested and went through the trial and
then got convicted,
how much time would you do?
I don't know.
It's interesting.
It's like,
would it be better karmically to go to jail for what he did come back,
go to jail and then no one.
Everyone would always know.
When you got out that you were convicted and you were punished for child
molestation,
like you did it and they got you.
Everyone would know.
Whereas now he's living in France and he has to deal with it floating over his
head.
Everyone who meets me knows that I drugged and raped a kid everywhere I go,
everyone knows I drugged and raped a kid and it just keeps playing out in his
head all day long.
Public shaming is powerful shit.
Well,
I mean that's the highest level.
This is drugging and raping a kid.
I'm a forgiving guy.
Can't forgive that one.
I can't like,
I'm a forgiving dude,
man.
I can't.
I don't stay mad and I think it's good to be forgiving about things.
There are certain things that to me when you,
and he's a great filmmaker and a great artist for me,
that kind of stuff.
It's very difficult,
man.
I'm just,
it's very difficult.
I had an argument with a bunch of older actors about this and they were all
saying it was a long time ago.
She looked up,
I mean I was like,
if it was your daughter and she was 13 how would you feel?
You just got to keep going back to that and well especially if you actually have
a daughter,
you actually have a daughter that's not,
you're not conceptualizing that your gut,
it actually locked into your brain.
You're actually thinking about your daughter and it becomes a different
completely different thing.
I remember thinking when I was young,
you know?
Yeah,
if someone did that to my daughter,
but that was like a,
before I had a kid who was like,
that was just a weird concept.
Didn't seem real.
But now you think about this 13 year old girl and you're like,
Whoa,
but what a court would do and what a,
what a trial would do is you might hear something like,
I don't know,
but you might hear,
I don't know.
She said,
she said she was 20 when we talk about drugging,
hold on.
She smoked a little weed that that guy gave her over there.
Let's be careful.
Right.
And then,
yeah,
then you start hearing all the extenuating circumstances and maybe you would go,
you got to do the time,
but at least I get how that happened because you thought it was something
different.
Right.
What was your intention?
What did you see?
But we don't know that.
So what happens is we start,
and we're doing this too and I'm doing it.
I don't know.
I don't know all the details of the case.
So all I'm saying is that he drugged and sodomized at 13 year old that everyone
was drugged,
him included.
Well there's this what I'm saying.
So we all have to be,
we all have to be careful and I have to to,
cause I'm,
I'm kind of breaking my own rule here.
I'm,
I'm drawing these very strong,
hard and fast,
uh,
like there's no context and what I'm saying,
right.
There's no nuance in what I'm saying.
If there's no context,
right.
And you gotta be careful cause everything has nuance and context in a way.
Otherwise,
otherwise,
otherwise you're taking me at just the words I'm saying.
So what I'm seeing from this,
this is like she's upset and you're upset.
Like she's upset,
she signed it and you're upset.
She signed it.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean nearly as much to me.
Like people making a mistake,
like her making that mistake doesn't mean much to me.
It's just a mistake.
It doesn't give it,
I'm not going to,
I'm not saying there's no consequences.
No one got hurt because that mistake,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it was a mistake.
She fucked up,
but it didn't ultimately hurting anyone.
Like it doesn't,
I don't like the fact that someone would at least temporarily have that thought
in their mind.
Like that guy should be free.
Like leave him alone.
What's bygones be bygones?
Actually talking about something different.
What are you talking about?
So I'm talking about talking about Hollywood tends to do,
I was just using her as an example.
Hollywood tends to do that,
which is popular,
that which is going to make them liked rather than something that's morally or
ethically consistent shots.
What I mean,
right.
We've talked about this before,
that it all comes down to the whole process of being chosen to do things or the
being chosen to direct or chosen to act or chosen.
Everybody's constantly working to be chosen.
You're all trying to audition for things or trying to angle to get a certain
role.
It's a constant process of like me,
like me,
like me.
And these are people that go into this job with his yearning,
desire to be loved.
And then on top of that they're playing this weird political game.
I mean,
acting is all political.
This,
I mean it doesn't make any sense that every other occupation except maybe tech
tax.
Probably like mostly mostly liberal,
but Hollywood's almost exclusively liberal.
And if you step out of those lines,
nobody wants to work with you anymore.
Hollywood on the surface is liberal,
but actually nobody who's conservative or whatever will speak out.
Right.
Like Tim Allen lost his show because he's,
because he's conservative.
He's an old white guy.
What he expect.
Yeah.
Oh,
white guys.
Yeah,
that's it.
The golf probably a very real thing nowadays.
Hanging out with Dennis Miller.
Dennis Miller,
same thing.
He went fucking James boats.
James Woods,
Brad James Woods is arguing with people on Twitter.
Like James,
you're seven years.
It's crazy.
I mean,
days you got left.
How many,
how many moments in your life do you really have left?
You have a thousand.
Like what are you going to do?
You're going to waste 400 of them on Twitter.
Yeah.
That's not wise.
That's not a wisely,
he said he was blackballed for his conservative views.
Was He really?
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
I don't need was I,
again,
I don't want to be,
um,
I don't know if I'm being helpful.
Right.
So,
well,
so you know,
you call out certain people or you talking about the inconsistencies.
Most people are doing the best they can and trying to make the world a better
place.
Right?
So are there,
I think most people would just look rolling downhill in a hamster wheel.
I makes,
I'm trying to figure out how to stop this fucking thing.
Yeah.
Most people are just on full on momentum.
Most people are definitely not thinking about how to make the world a better
place.
Occasionally people think of that.
What they try to think is,
how do I get buy number one?
Yeah.
And then how do I get better?
How do I get ahead?
Number two,
those are the things they think of,
and occasionally what's going on?
What's,
stop it over there.
Yeah.
Fucking Trump,
and then they go back to work.
Yeah.
That's all you can do sometimes.
Most people,
that's most people.
Okay.